يُظهر مقطع فيديو جديد لكاميرا الجسم الشرطة في
براغ وهي تستجيب للهجوم الأكثر دموية في
وقت السلم في تاريخ التشيك الحديث.
يمكنك رؤية الضباط يبحثون
في أروقة الجامعة ويقومون
بإجلاء الأشخاص من المباني.
قُتل 14 شخصًا في الهجوم
وأصيب 25 آخرون مع اندلاع أعمال العنف.
بدأ الطلاب في حبس
أنفسهم في الفصول الدراسية، حتى أن بعضهم اختبأ
على حافة المبنى هربًا من
الهجوم، يمكنك رؤيتها هناك، إنها
صورة متناقضة تنضم إلينا
الآن ميليسا ميليسا، ماذا كنا نتعلم عن
مطلق النار
هنا
جيدًا، هذه لقطات كاميرا الجسم
يقدم حقًا نظرة ثاقبة تقشعر لها الأبدان حول ما
واجهه الكثير من هؤلاء الطلاب وهؤلاء المستجيبين الأوائل بالفعل
أه أثناء آه هذا الهيجان الذي قام به
طالب الفلسفة البالغ من العمر 24 عامًا آه الذي
قام بالهجوم أمس في
جامعة تشارلز، لقد كان الأمر بمثابة  دقائق محمومة أه
بالطبع حيث
حاولت الشرطة أه ليس فقط الدخول ومحاولة
منعه من قتل أي شخص آخر ولكن
فقط أه حاول تنفيذ تلك الشجرة
بين أه الشباب العديد منهم
بالطبع أه الذين كانوا في ذلك الوقت
مستلقين على أرضيات الفصول الدراسية الآن
لدينا فكرة أفضل أيضًا هذا الصباح
عن تسلسل الأحداث بالضبط،
فيل نفهم أن هذا
الشاب أه غادر منزله حيث
تم العثور على جثة والده أه ويعتقد
من قبل الشرطة التشيكية ذلك  لقد قتل
والده قبل أن يتوجه إلى جامعته
الآن، وقد تلقت الشرطة بلاغاً بأنه
كان يخطط لقتل نفسه
وكان مسلحاً، وقد قاموا بإخلاء
المبنى الذي كان من المفترض أن يلقي فيه
محاضرة في الساعة الثانية ظهراً بعد ظهر أمس، وهو
في الواقع في  جزء آخر من الحرم الجامعي أه
لقد تصرف بحيث لا
يمنع الإخلاء أي شيء على الإطلاق كانت هناك
بعض الأسئلة حتى هذا الصباح
أيضًا حول ما إذا كان قد تم القضاء عليه
من قبل الشرطة بعد الهجوم أثناء
الهجوم أو ما إذا كان قد تم قتله  لقد
أعلنت الشرطة الآن أنه
كان انتحارًا، وأعتقد أنه في أحد
أكثر التعليقات المخيفة التي تلقيناها
من الشرطة هذا الصباح قالوا
انظروا عندما ترى كم من الأسلحة
كان لديه هذا النوع من الذخيرة  لقد كان
بالفعل التدخل السريع
للشرطة أه هذا يعني أه أنه تم
إنقاذ الأرواح ومع ذلك أه فيل وبوبي أه
14 شخصًا قتلوا بالأمس في
ذلك الهجوم معظمهم من الطلاب قبل
أيام قليلة من عيد الميلاد يستعدون
للذهاب  كان
اثنان منهم من الموظفين في عطلة عيد الميلاد، ولكن في الواقع، جريمة
قتل مروعة هي أول جريمة قتل على
الإطلاق تحدث في مدرسة أو
كلية في تاريخ جمهورية التشيك.